السلام عليكم نظم مؤيد الرئيس المصري
المعزول محمد مرسي مسيرات بمشاركه الاف
النساء في القاهره والجيزه والاسكندريه
للتنديد بمقتل ثلاث متظاهرات في مدينه
المنصوره وط المتظاهرون المجلس القومي
لحقوق الانسان بحمايه المتظاهرات ووقف
الاعتداء عليهن نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش
في
محورين ما هي دوافع التعدي على النساء في
المظاهرات وضمانات عدم تحوله الى اداه
للصراع
السياسي اسباب تباين مواقف القوى السياسيه
المصريه من مقتل المتظاهرات الثلاث في
مدينه
المنصوره
خروج النساء مجددا في مظاهرات مؤيدي
الرئيس المصري المعزول محمد مرسي بدا
رساله تحد بعد مقتل ثلاث متظاهرات في
المنصوره وقد اجمعت كافه القوى السياسيه
المصريه على ادانه التعدي على النساء في
المظاهرات وطالبت السلطات بتوفير الحمايه
لهن لكن القوى والحركات المحسوبه على ما
يسمى بالتيار المدني في مصر لامت ايضا
جماعه الاخوان المسلمين على الدفع بالنساء
والاطفال للتظاهرات واعتبرت الامر محاوله
من الجماعه لجذب التعاطف
الشعبي لا يزال الشارع السياسي المصري
ملتهبا تظاهرات الالاف مؤيد الرئيس
المعزول محمد مرسي والمطالبين بعودته تجوب
المواقع والمدن ويسيطر الان على جانب كبير
من مشهدها القتلات الثلاث ال سقطنا على يد
بلطجيه في مظاهرات الجمعه بالمنصوره
والمطالبه بالقصاص لهن الحدث ما فتئ يفرز
ردود فعل واسعه لدى مختلف الاطياف كل طيف
يرسم المشهد بريشته ويدينه بطريقته اكتفى
محمد البرادعي نائب الرئيس المصري المؤقت
للعلاقات الدوليه بتدوينه على موقعه
بتويتر تساءل متى نتعلم ان العنف يفاقم
المشاكل ولا يحلها وهو ما انتقده عدد من
شباب الثوره ذكروه بانه بات مسؤولا في
الدوله عليه تجاوز دور الناشط المعارض
ودان حمدين صباح المرشح الرئاسي السابق
ومؤسس التيار الشعبي دان الاحداث ايضا في
تغريده بتويتر لكنه وصف ما حدث بانه لا
يبرئ وحشيه من سماهم بالمتعقب الذين القوا
بهن الى التهلكه على حد تعبيره مختلف
الجهات السياسيه والدينيه والاجتماعيه في
مصر دانت حادث المنصوره والعنف ضد
المتظاهرين عامه وحمل كثيرون منهم وزاره
الداخليه المسؤوليه عن تنام احداث البلطجه
كما انتقدوا الجيش لما وصفوه بتمييزه في
طريقه تامين المظاهرات المؤيده للتغييرات
الراهنه وبين المعارضه التي تطالب بعوده
الرئيس المعزول مصرع النساء الثلاث في
المنصوره يعيد للاذهان ممارسات عنف مشابهه
ضد المتظاهرين جرت في عهود سابقه مثل
ارهاب المتظاهرين عبر ارهاب المتظاهرات
والتي مارسها نظام الرئيس المخلوع حسني
مبارك في ال من مايو عام 2005 بحق
المتظاهرات امام نقابه الصحفيين ورغم
اختلاف اليوم عن الامس وادراك مختلف
الاطياف لحجم وخطوره التداعيات الامنيه
الكامنه وراء التهاب الشارع فان الرؤيه
الكامله للاحداث وتطوراتها وتداعياتها
وانعكاساتها على الجميع لا تزال ضبابيه
غير واضحه
المعالم موضوع حلقتنا نناقش مع ضيوفنا من
القاهره محمد عباس عضو الهيئه العليا لحزب
التيار المصري وفي الاستوديو عماد الدين
حسين رئيس تحرير صحيفه الشروق وفي بدايه
برنامجنا معنا من المنصوره الان محمد ابو
شعيشع وهو ووالد الضحيه هاله محمد ابو
شعيشع وهي كما ذكرنا احدى ض ضحايا مظاهرات
المنصوره سيد محمد ابو شعيشع تعازينا
بدايه ونود ان نعرف منكم الروايه التي
تمكنتم ربما من الوصول الى تفاصيلها اكثر
من اي شخص
اخر بحيي حضرتك
وبحيي الجهاز الفني اللي موجود معتك اهلا
وسهلا وبقول كلمه بس تعليق بسيط جدا قبل
ما ادخلك في الموضوع تعليق على ت البدعي
والسيد حمين صباحي انا شايف ان المواطنين
والاطفال والشباب والرجال والنساء وكل
فئات الشعب المصري مسلمين ومسحين مواطنين
صالحين من حقهم ان هم يتظاهروا ومن حقهم
ان هم ينزلوا ومن حقهم ان هم يعبروا عن
رايهم ومن حقهم ان هم يعتم طالما ان هم
سنيين مين اللي قال ان في حد بيق حد وحد
بيضحي
بحد المبدا والمنهج غير سوي غير مظبوط انا
بستغرب نفس في المجال السياسي بهم فتره
طويله جدا جدا يتكلم ويحي بكلام على كده
ازاي احنا ابتنا بعد الثوره من حق اي واحد
ان هو يتظاهر بقراه سلنيه من حق اي مواطن
كبير او صغير يعمل بالحكومه اولا يعمل
بالحكومه ان هو يعتصم في المكان بدون ان
هو ما يعطش حد ولا يضر حد اما يقول ان
فيور في الوقت اللي احنا شغالين
فيه البسيط حتك يعني نعم استذ سيد محمد
نود طبعا نتفهم تماما شعوركم ونود ان
تشاركنا لو سمحت روايتك لما حدث مع ابنتكم
في
المنصوره انا حضرتك كت ضع العدويه يوم
الجمعه ك ضع العدويه وجت لي رساله فانا
كشاهد كشاهد عيال عشان اقول الحقيقه انا
نازل لاث بنات عندي كبيره و
الشري نازلين مع بعض طبعا
وبعد مامنا هار وتقبلنا فيها العزاء حت
قعدت مع صفيه عشان اعرف بالتفصيل بالضبط
يعني طبعا صفيه مهاره جدا جدا لان هي اللي
اكبر من هنا مباشره و يا بابا احنا
تعاملوا معانا زي القطع هم كانوا عندهم
وقفه وصلاه تراويح وخيان عند استاد استاد
المنصوره وتحركوا من عند الاستاد في شارع
في شارع عبد السلام عارف من الااد منصوره
في اتجاه شارع السرعه وعدوا ده انتوا
ماشيين مظاهره سلميه ف كل الناس الكبير
والصغير بنا فهم الفله
الاموره الحلوه هاله هاله دي فيهم
هاله على كل الات مصحب على كل الناس وب كل
الناس
و حد و يعني بتحت من حد دهم مستمرين في
المسره لحد ما تخلوا شارع
السعه المسافه دي قول تيجي كيلو ونص تيجي
ا كيلو تيجي 3 كيلو اصبح في في مسافات
بعيده ما بين الناس اللي ماشيين في
المظاهره وما بين
بعضهم والبنات والنساء ماشيين ورا
التروسكل اللي جاي اللي عليه المقسرات
اسلوب والرجال كانوا لسه جايين ورا طلع
لهم بلطجيه من شارع الترعه استغلوا فرصه
ان هم الموجودين بع لوحدهم كووا مخدرات
الصوط واشتغلوا ك طحم يعني كلمه من بق
الناس الي طحم يا بابا نزلوا فينا طحم يا
بابا طحم اللي يق على الارض واللي يقعد
تاني واللي يتحرك وما يناش في الوقت ده
قبل الوقت دي شويه صغيرين كانت خفيه
والشهيده هاله واختهم خديجه كانوا ماشيين
مع بعض لما هجوا علوم البلطجيه قال كان
معاها بنت صغيره اخت واحده صاحبتها وصفيه
ماسه خديجه اختها سيد محمد واحده مشيت
النحيادي سيد محمد ساعتذر منك فقط لضيق
الوقت لاننا نود فعلا مناقشه هذا الموضوع
من مختلف الزوايا اشكرك جزيل الشكر على
مشاركتك هذه هو
مشاركتنا ربما وجهه نظرك وما شاهدته انت
عما حدث لهاله وزميلته اثنتان معها اشكرك
جزيل الشكر طبعا السيد محمد ابو شعيشع هو
والد احدى ضحايا مظاهرات المنصوره نتحول
الان الى ضيوفنا نبدا من الاستوديو السيد
عماد الدين حسين نرحب بك سمعت لما قاله
السيد محمد ابو شعيش ما الذي يبرر استعمال
العنف ضد متظاهرات سلمي خرجنا في نهايه
الامر للتعبير عن وجهه نظرهن انا للاسف
الصوت لم يكن واضحا جيدا لكن في كل
الاحوال الاجابه على هذا السؤال لا شيء في
الدنيا كلها يبرر ما حدث في المنصوره اي
اعتداء على اي متظاهر يعني ولو بحجر غير
مقبول شكلا وموضوعا وبالتالي بغض النظر عن
الموقف السياسي للشخص مع او ضد
ا لا يمكن له تبرير ما حدث يعني هذا فعل
ينبغي ان يدام باشد العبارات الممكنه
وينبغي ان يتحمل الذين فرطوا في هذا حق
مسؤوليتهم الى من يمكن ان نشير هنا يتحمل
من فرط في مسؤولياته في هذا الموضوع سمعنا
بعض الاطراف من القوى السياسيه المصريه
تحمل يعني حتى من وصفوهم من زج بهم الى
الشارع ودفع بهم الى الخروج الى التظاهر
اليس حق التظاهر مكفولا للجمع لا انا انا
بس عايزين يعني عايز احط نقطه لان هذه
المساله في غايه الاهميه في مصر البعض
يقول ان الناس دين ثم تقول ولكن ام خلينا
نتفق ان هذا فعل مدان تماما لا احد يقبل
تحت اي مسمى من حق المتظاهرات الذين خرجنا
بالامس ومن حق انصار الاخوان المسلمين ان
يخرجوا في اي وقت ويتظاهر طالما كانت
المظاهره سلميه وليس من حق احد ان يعني
يعتدي عليهم ولو هم خرجوا وخلفوا القانون
من حقه ان هو يتعامل معهم في اطار القانون
وفي معروف في الدنيا كلها اسمها حاجه
اسمها قواعد الاشتباك ان انا لو حتى
المتظاهرين او المتظاهرات انتهكوا القانون
او انتهك القانون بعمل تحذير بعمل قنابل
مثيره للدموع بعمل ضرب بالعصي بعمل ضرب في
اسوا الاحوال في الرجلين ثم لما يكون في
حاجه مميته استعمل الرصاص الحي عندما تكون
هناك يعني حاله حقيقيه من الخطر فبالتالي
يعني ما حدث في المنصوره ينبغي ادانته بكل
الطرق نقطه من اول السط الداخليه وتعاملها
مع المظاهرات في مصر منذ 25 ناير هذه
مشكله شائكه المسائل مش مثاليه انت ما
بتتحدث في لندن البوليس ينبغي انه بيحرص
المظاهره المظاهره تروح بتعمل تصريح
وبتاخد التصريح وعارف مكان تحركها وبعد
كده مفترض ان يحرسه ويتحمل المسؤوليه
البوليس المصري منذ 25 يناير كان هو هدف
للمتظاهرين فبعيد طول الوقت كان الجيش
والشرطه عملوا حاجه غريبه وقتها قالوا
احموا نفسكم في التحرير ثم تطور الامر انه
بعد بعد 30 يونيو الجيش الشرطه رجعت الى
الميادين مره اخرى لكن مع لكن بق خصم
للاخوان المسلمين الروايات مره ثانيه
الفعل المدان ما حدث في المنصور الف هناك
اكثر من روايه لا لا نعلم لا احد قدم لنا
روايه حققيه سمعت روايه تقول ان البلطجيه
ضربوا رصاص مباشر على الضحايا وبعضهم
ومنهم الشهيده هاله طلق ناري في الظهر
والبعض يقول ان هناك مناوشات حدثت يعني
النهارده المجلس القومي للمراه صحيح هذا
هذا حتى لجنه تقرير تقصي الحقائق في احداث
المنصوره خالصه الى ان طرفان من مؤيدين
ومعارضين تشابكه ووزاره الداخليه هي التي
تدخلت لفض هذه الاشتباكات سيد عماد الدين
فقط حتى نتحول الى ضيفنا القاهره ساعود
اليك حتما خلال هذا اللقاء ومعنا من هناك
ضيفنا محمد عباس عضو الهيئه العليا لحزب
التيار المصري الان اذا ما تحدثنا عن
الموضوع من وجهه نظر الطبقه السياسيه
مختلف القوى السياسيه كيف تعاملت معه كيف
يمكن ان نقيم ردود الفعل على الحادث سيد
محمد عباس كيف
تابعته يعني مبدئيا انا احب اعزي الشهداء
شهيدات المنصوره
اللي حصل دي جريمه بكل المقاييس لا احد
يستطيع ان يبررها او يضع كلمه لكن في اخر
اي جمله تتحدث في ادانه هذا الامر للاسف
الشديد بعض النخبه المصريه واختص هنا
بالكلام بذكر الدكتور البرادعي وحمدين
صباحي تحديدا
الاثنين مواقفهم مخزيه جدا جدا من الموقف
اللي حصل اول امس الدكتور البرادعي طلع
تحدث بتويتر بيتكلم فيها ان العنف لا ي
الى العنف وقلنا ان العنف لا يحل الازمه
دكتور البرادي انت نائب رئيس الجمهوريه
انت قلت لمحمد مرسي عندما كان رئيسا عندما
سقطت دماء في المظاهرات قلت له الان فقدت
شرعيتك يا ترى هل تستطيع ان تقول لنفسك
هذا الكلام في هذه اللحظه ان انك فقدت
شرعيتك نحن في ازمه حقيقيه منذ الثوره نحن
نعلم من قبل الثوره ان هناك تنظيم بلطجيه
تابع لوزاره الداخليه تستخدم تستخدم وزاره
الداخليه هذا التنظيم في لحظات لا تريد ان
تتعامل بشكل مباشر مع المظاهرات عملت
الكلام دوت في الانفلات الامني في الثوره
في وقت قبل موقعه الجمل ووقت موقعه الجمل
وقامت بالكلام دوت في فتره لما كان حكم
العسكر شغال في مواقف مختلفه كلمه
المواطنين والشرفاء ودلوقتي ب اذا انت
تشير تماما سيد محمد عباس فقط حتى نتطور
بالفكره انت تشير الى ما مخاوف عديده في
الواقع عبر عنها كثيرون من ان تتحول مثل
هذه الممارسات الى ربما اداه سياسيه
لتخويف الشارع مصري قمع المتظاهرات في
اشاره ربما الى تخويف المتظاهرين كما حدث
حتى في عهد النظام
السابق لا لا ده ده الحاصل ده بيحصل بقاله
فتره طويله من ايام حكم المجلس العسكري ده
مش اول مره نلاقي بلطجيه بيواجه ونا
ويقولوا المواطنين الشرفاء العباسيه واحد
والعباسيه اثنين شهداء على هذا الامر
ويطلع يقولوا ان الاهالي هي اللي بتواجه
لا ده مش الاهالي دي البلطجيه التابعه
للنظام القمعي الامني اللي موجود فيها
الدول الوله ده رجوع وانتكاسه حقيقيه
للثوره المصريه انتكاسه ان الداخليه ترجع
لسابق عملها بهذا الشكل القذر اللي احنا
عارفينه واللي احنا قمنا ضده بالثوره احنا
عندنا ا نقاط واضحه جدا هي التعامل الامني
مع المتظاهرين بيصدروا لهم البلطجيه وهم
يقعدوا يتفرجوا انا شفت بنفسي في احداث
المقطم شفت مفتش المباحث بتاع بتاع المقطم
واقف بيوجه البلطجيه ازاي يهاجموا مقر
الاخوان المسلمين انا كنت نزلت اشوف ايه
الحدث بالظبط لقيته هو اللي بيوجه شفنا في
بين السرايات الداخليه و الظباط واقفين
والبلطجيه يخرجوا من وراهم بالسلاح يضربوا
الناس ويرجعوا ورا ورا الداخليه يتحامل في
الداخليه نيجي لنقطه انيه ودي نقطه مهمه
جدا جدا نقطه شيطنه المؤيد الرئيس بعيدا
عن اختلافنا واتفقنا مع المطالب اللي
بيطلبوها بعوده الدكتور محمد مرسي سواء
اتفقنا واختلافنا فيها لكن تعال نيجي نشوف
اللي حصل دوت بيحصل ازاي نلاقي ان هم في
كل المواقع المختلفه في بين السرايات وبعض
في المنيال وفي كذا منطقه في وفي رمسيس
طلعوا البلطجيه والشرطه بتساعدهم انا نزلت
في رمسيس وشفت الشرطه وهي واقفه فوق كوبري
اكتوبر بتضرب الغاز والبلطجيه تحت
بيضربوا الثوار بشكل مباشر النقطه الاخيره
ودي النقطه المهمه احنا في ازدواجيه
للمعايير هي ازدواجيه ان النخبه كانت
بتاخذ على الاخوان بعض المواقف اللي هم
بياخدوها في في رد فعل على المقاسي
والمواقف الانسانيه المختلفه اللي حصلت
الفتره اللي فاتت اهمها نقطه ست البنات في
2011 لما العسكر عروها وداسوا عليها
برجليهم ساع متاز جدا انت اشرت الى نقطه
سيد محمد وهي واضحه تماما سنش بعها نقاشا
مع ضيفنا هنا واتحول بها للسيد عماد الدين
هنا في الاستوديو مساله ازدواجيه المعايير
من كان بالامس يدافع عن حق المتظاهرات
للخروج على الشارع يلومن الان يعني هل لنا
ان نفهم يعني ما الذي يريده هؤلاء بالضبط
كيف يمكن تبرير هذه الازدواجيه هذهه نقطه
مهمه ينبغي ان توجه الى افراد التيار جزء
كبير من التيار الاسلامي مش كلهم انا متفق
مع معظم ما ذهب اليه الدكتور محمد عباس
ومره تانيه بعزي والد الشهيده وكل الشهداء
لكن خلونا نناقش المساله في اطارها الصحيح
هذه الفتاه التي سحلت في التحرير التيار
الاسلامي غالبيته مش كله قال ايه اللي
وداها التحرير ليه البنات تنزل لكن في
المقابل
التظاهر ت خرظه لم انا على حد عم لا يوجد
اي تصريح ارجو ان حد يذكر من في القوى
الليبراليه خرج وهاجم او انتقد خروج
الفتات للتظاهر في المنصوره لحث نتحدث
الان حمدين صباحي قال نلوم الكلام لحمدين
صباحي هو موجود نلوم من زج بهن ودفعه
للخروج الى الشارع يتحدث عن الاخوان تح لا
لا لا كان يتحدث عن ان في روايه واضحه من
احد الاخوان قال انه تلقى تحذير ان هناك ك
بلطجيه يتربصون بالمظاهره في اخر الشارع
لانه شارع معروف فيه تجمع بلطجيه شارع
اسمه شارع الترعه وطلب منهم ان يغيروا
مسارهم حتى لا يحتكوا فقال له هذا هو
المسار المرسوم امامي بغض النظر هو من حقه
انه يتظاهر في اي وقت ومن حق الداخليه
والدوله ان تحميهم لكن القصه بتاعه ست
البنات التي سحلت والتيار الاسلامي كله
قال ليه تروح التحرير وليه تلبس عبايه
بكباسين كلام فاضي وتافه للاسف قيل وقتها
النقطه الاهم يعني اذكر الناس وماذا عن
الذي يقال الان اعود مره اخرى بس في شيء
مهم للغايه وزير الداخليه وزير عدل محمد
مرسي المستشار احمد مكي ها خرج وقال انا
اتصلت بوزير الداخليه وزير داخليه محمد
مرسي وكان هناك روا يعني حادث الشهير اسمه
حادث محمد الجندي هذا شاب ينتمي الى
التيار الشعبي وجد مدرجا بدماه ومقتول
حققه دخل الطب الشرعي قال حاد السياره
لانه وزير الداخليه وزير العدل قال انا
اتصلت بوزير الداخليه وطلبت منه او وزير
الداخليه اتصل ب وقال لي ارجوك قل انه حدث
سياره تم تشكيل لجنه تحقيق ثانيه ثبتت انه
مات معذبا فبالتالي علينا ان ندين العنف
والانتهاك حقوق الانسان في كل وقت وفي لا
نقف عند ان ان هذا ينتقد او هذا يعني نقطه
اخرى حمدين صباحي ومحمد البراد س سنعود
سنعود لموقف طبقه السياسيه استسمحك عذرا
فقط لان سنذهب في فاصل قصير نواصل بعد
حتما النقاش حول مواقف هذه القوى السياسيه
المصريه من مقتل ثلاث متظاهرات في مدينه
المنصور ابقوا
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
تناقش مواقف القوى السياسيه المصريه من
مقتل ثلاث متظاهرات في مدينه المنصوره
اعود اليك سريعا سيد عماد الدين قبل ان
نتحول القاهره في هذه النقطه المتعلقه
بمواقف القوى السياسيه سمعنا والد الضحيه
هال السيد محمد ابو شعيشع سمعنا ضيفنا
ايضا من القاهره محمد عباس يدينان وهو في
الواقع صوت سمعناه من اكثر من طرف ربما
موقف البرادعي الذي هو الان عضو فاعل في
النظام اكتفى بتغريده تندد حمدين صباحي
مره اخرى تغريده اخرى يقول دم شهيدات
المنصوره يدينه يدين وحشيه المجرمين الذين
قتلوهم ولا يبرئ وحشيه المتعصبين الذين
القوه الى التهلكه ويجب عليهم الاعتزال هو
بيلوم الاثنين بيلوم في الاساس الذين يعني
المجرمين الذين قتلوا الفتيات ماذا عن
البرادعي هل تجد موقفه متسقا مع منصبه
الجديد هذه نقطه في غيه الاهميه نسال ما
هو دور حمدين صباحي زعيم سياسي مصري ليس
في الحكومه وبالتالي ادان الق بوضوح ماذا
كان مطلوبا منب وهذا سؤال بسيط زي بالضبط
هرجع تاني دائما لما نقارن بين الاشياء
عندما قتل اكثر من متظاهر او اكثر من ناشط
مصري اثناء حكم الرئيس محمد مرسي ها
الرئيس محمد مرسي ادان الحوادث وطلب
بالتحقيق يعني ماذا ما هو المطلوب من رئيس
الجمهوريه في هذه اللحظه ان
يفعل محمد البردعي ادان ووزير العدل الذي
يمثل حكومه او الحكومه طلبت اجراء تحقيق
عادل وشفاف اذا المطلوب هو مجرد ادانه حسب
وجهه نظرك ينبغي ان يديم بوضوح بلا لبس
والدوله ينبغي ان تتحرك بصوره على اجراء
تحقيق عاجل وشفاف د نتحول السيد محمد عباس
لنعرف وجهه نظره اذا المطلوب من البرادعي
هو ادانه صريحه وشفافه ما تقييمك انت وقد
اشرت الى هذه النقطه ما المطلوب ما الذي
تريدونه تحديدا منه ما الذي اغضبك في هذه
التغريده او اغضب العديدين ممن
انتقدوها لا يعني انا بمثل هنا مش بمثل
اخوان المسلمين انا بمثل شباب جزء من شباب
الثوره اغلبهم كانوا في حمل الدكتور بدعي
الناس كانت تنتظر من الدكتور البرادعي
موقفا اكثر قوه واكثر حده في من هذا الامر
هو نائب رئيس الجمهوريه عليه ان يتحرك
بقوه في
مواجهه وزير الداخليه اللي هو مسؤول بشكل
اساسي على اللي حصل خلينا نرجع لنقطه انيه
الاستاذ الدكتور عماد ذكرها في النص هي
نقطه وزاره الداخليه ومحمد الجندي اللي
اتقتل اللي هو وزير الداخليه دلوقتي هو
نفسه اللي قتل محمد الجندي لو احنا بنتكلم
على نفس الازمه هو وزير الداخليه اللي في
الحكومه الحاليه اللي احنا بنقول ان هو
تصحيح مسار الثوره اذا اذا اعتبرنا ان هذا
تصحيحا لمسار الثوره هو رئيس هو وزير
الداخليه نفسه هو اللي قتل محمد الجندي
قبل كده عن طريق داخليته يعني احنا عندنا
في نفس الموقف احنا ما اختلفناش كتير
النقطه الثانيه ودي النقطه المهمه وانا
عايز اركز عليها ظهرت الفتره اللي فاتت
نقاط مهمه جدا جدا جدا هي مهاجمه ثوره 25
يناير وشباب ثوره 25 يناير ظهرت عن طريق
بعض المقالات اللي اتنشرت اليومين اللي
فاتوا واتقال على شباب الثوره باسمائهم ان
هم مرتزقه 25 يناير وفي اعلامي كبير في
قناه اعلاميه كبيره تحدث بالامس وقال انا
شباب ثوره 25 يناير يدون ان ياخذوا البلد
الى كانوا يريدون ان ياخذوا البلد الى
الهويه واخذوها في خلال سنتين ونصف الى
الهويه وكل دوت وجود رمز ثوري محترم زي
الدكتور محمد برادعي نائبا للرئيس ولا
يتحدث ولا يقول ان ولا يدافع عن هذه
الثوره ن ال تنظرونه من
د انا انتظر منه ان يمثل الثوره انا انتظر
منه ان هو يمثل مطالب الثوره انتظر منه ان
يمثل الحريات انتظر منه ان هو يتحرك بشكل
حقيقي عن طريق السلطات ان هو نائب رئيس
الجمهوريه ان هو يتحرك ويوقف هذا الكلام
بشكل واضح احنا كنا بناخد على الاخوان ان
هم بيهاجموا الثوره وان هم بيمروا ضدها
دلوقتي في رمز للثوره جوه الدوله الجديده
بالشكل الجديد وه لا يتحدث ولا يقول اي
شيء ولا يقف وقفه واضحه يقول ان ما يحدث
هو جريمه حقيقيه عل على المسؤول عنها
المحاسبه عليه ان يوجه رسالته الى وزير
الداخليه ان يقيل مدير امن المنصوره مثلا
الذي قثر كثيرا في فيما حدث بالامس معروف
ان البلطجيه يتحركون في كل مكان في الدوله
بشكل واضح وصريح اين الداخليه في في القبض
عليهم مش موجوده في ظل وجود الدكتور
البرادعي في السلطه جزء من السلطه هنقول
ان هو اختصاصه العلاقات الخارجيه لكن انا
انا شايف ان هو نائب رئيس الجمهوريه ويه
سلطات يجب ان يتحر في خلالها نعم حتى لا
نحصر النقاش في شخص واحد او جزء واحد من
النظام اختلفت طبعا وتباينت مواقف مختلف
القوى السياسيه ما الذي ادى الى هذا
التباين باعتقادك في هذه الحادثه تحديدا
التي قلت بانه يجب ان يكون الموقف صريح
حازم حاسم وواضح تجاهها نعم المشكله انه
في استقطاب حاد كل واحد بيرى يعني عندما
يعني يقتل له قتيل او يسقط له شهيد فيبقى
هو المظلوم الوحيد لكن عندما يسقط للطرف
الاخر فلا يراه هذه مشكله حقيق ق في
الاستقطاب تمت قبل ذلك وب بتتم الان بس هو
لو كل فصيل سياسي يتذكر ماذا فعل في يعني
كان الله سبحانه وتعالى بيريد ان يعاقب
القوه السياسيه كلها لانه بيحطوا في
الموقفين مع بعض في موقف قوى سياسيه في
موقف تبقى السيدات ما ينفعش يطلعوا من
بيوتهم لان هي بيتها مكانها المطبخ والبيت
والانجاب ها لكن عندما تخرج معه تبقى
شهيده وطيبه والعكس صحيح للطرف الاخر
فبالتالي على القوى السياسيه ان تكون اكثر
مبدئيه وعلى ان تتعامل مع المسائل هذه
المسائل بمبدئ وان هم يؤمنوا فعلا انه
التظاهر حق طبيعي للاسف الشديد في معظم
الاحداث ما الذي يضمن الان ان يكون فعلا
التظاهر حق طبيعي وان يكفل للجميع ايا كان
يعني لونه وطيفه السياسي باختصار لوس الذي
يضمن له ذلك هي حركه الشارع والناس تتظاهر
سلميا يعني انا في في حاجات ما ينفعش
يدافع عنها فكره اللي خرجنا امبارح في
المنصوره واختنا لابد من ادانه وعقاب شديد
جدا لكن ما ينفعش اروح اقطع طريق كبري
سريح في كوبري اكتوبر في وص في مدار رمسيس
واقول ان انا بصلي التراويح انت بتعطل مص
الناس وتخلي الناس على هذا يبرر قتل المت
لا لا لا لا اطلاق لا لا ده انا بتحدث على
فرنسيس فاللي بيحدث بينزل في ناس انا
شفتهم بعيني بينزلوا من السيارات
بيتخانقوا مع الناس اللي قاطعين الطريق
انانه عايز يروح علينا ان ندين باشد
العبارات الممكنه ما حدث في المنصوره وما
يحدث وما حدث من قتل منذ اول يوم للثوره
حتى هذه اللحظه لكن لا نكيل بمكيالين
اشكرك جزيل الشكر سيد عماد الدين حسين
رئيس تحرير صحيفه الشروق كما نشكر ضيفنا
من القاهره السيد محمد عباس عض الهيئه
العليا لحزب التيار المصري ونشكر ضيفنا
طبعا والد هاله محمد ابو الشعيشع الضحيه
التي قضت في مظاهرات المنصوره السيد محمد
ابو شعيشع الذي كان معنا من المنصوره
وبهذا مشاهدينا الكرام تنتهي هذه الحلقه
من برنامج ما وراء الخبر نلتقي باذن الله
في قراءه جديده في ما وراء خبر جديد
السلام
عليكم
ا